but what is the greatest moment for you
of your you know I was boxing is on its
way I'm Mike Tyson
I live in Britain and I guess here today
is Piers Morgan hey very excited to be
here I was talking earlier pier thumb we
actually are you filming that actually
from London England not from the south
so it's just south of London about an
hour south on the south coast brought up
a little village my parents run a
country pub so I grew up in an
environment where most nights people
were drinking too much getting into
fights and my dad having to throw them
into the street so you know I'd have
bruising upbringing but you think you
had it should have been in my village in
those early years I've been doing most
of my life right telling me they're
feeling loved you did more than three or
three years you can't come back in from
that fact and every time I've been to
those guys though they're like legendary
folk Lloyd you know they remember the
past the tough bad man and a real
bare-knuckle fight now we're a national
Warriors it's just me absolutely nice
Brits are up for a scrap yeah what feeds
a member who your foots either who your
foot do you see the foot yes yes do you
remember that yeah yeah but listen Mike
and I mean in Britain Mike is it
absolute icon yeah I mean I remember you
going down I think the last time you
came over I remember I think you went
down to Brixton or somewhere with that
crazy and the crate was honestly it was
as if my dad Oregon down there it was
nuts but I remember thinking that was a
really it was a really interesting thing
to watch to see someone like you down
there and the crowds that came out very
powerful to me I was overwhelming to me
at that time like I bet you know when
was that I don't know
then I don't know what time is now this
is crazy because we had a funny size I
used to run a newspaper cool with Daily
Mirror one of the big and when you
fought Julius Francis do you remember
that Julius Francis was he wasn't a
great father to be honest with you but
Frank Warren has set up this fight with
you and Julius Francis so I rang Frank
and I said look is there any sponsorship
available on Julius Francis oh yeah
so he said he said what what do you mean
what are you thinking he said I said
well has anybody as anybody sponsored
the seat of his pants and the soles of
his feet nice shoes soles of his shoes
so Frank because what do you what are
you getting out when look if we would
have offered twenty thousand pounds
could we put the Daily Mirror logo on
his backside and on the soles of his
feet because I've got a feeling we're
gonna be seeing a lot of that TV and the
funny thing was it was airing on Sky
Sports which is Rupert Murdoch who with
a rival newspaper group as well because
they had the Sun so Julius Francis gets
it against Mike and I watching it live I
would think he come up might just knock
him over at least four or five times
with the with our logo yeah over in they
can say at least I Paul he saw his feet
like this with daily mirror mirror on
and we did I remember the front page I
can remember it the whole front page is
a picture of his over the feet like this
and it just said pride in defeat I have
to say this said I know I spend a lot of
time in England been a man I've been on
like I'm tours in England I would go now
go from I was stuff from London and we
would go all the way up to York
Doncaster all this time Birmingham you
just keep going Dobby it kept going me
as you like if you like I love to just
people sports meet and greet having
dinners two times 3,000 people it's
crazy fish and chips with mushy peas
might know okay here we have fish and
chips
fish and chips up north so what got you
into the UM shoe business
well I always wanted to be a journalist
so from an early age I just was obsessed
with news and newspapers and then I did
it in the conventional way I trained to
be a journalist went on local papers for
a couple of years in Wimbledon in South
London with the tennessee's we're Maldon
users my first paper and then I worked
my way up onto the national papers and
then ended up becoming the youngest ever
editor of a national daily newspaper I
must have been a head trip for you it
was a pretty you know it's a very
interesting thing isn't it weather where
there's a fearlessness of youth and I
know that you must have felt that when
you were watching you fight when you
were 20 21 and you were completely
fearless and that fearlessness as you
get older it becomes you know the you
lose a little bit of the fearlessness
once you start having commitments and
mortgages and and kids and all the rest
of it I think there is that thing when
you're young that you have I certainly
felt it when I walked into that newsroom
with all these journalists most of whom
we were older than me that I had to
somehow get their authority and I had to
run this extraordinary newspaper and I
did it for 10 years but I remember
thinking it was easier when I was
younger and my head was a bit clearer
and I had that fearless thing than when
I was a bit older hey listen I come all
the time
Rupert Murdoch in their paper they were
they were have they had like ransom that
then I might rewards that they can give
you can get pictures of certain
celebrities in awkward positions and
stuff yeah this is the British tabloids
are rougher stop murdering roughly some
dude imma tell you the difference
between the Americans and the English
tabloids right
the American people want wants to sue
you for money the tablet isn't this ruin
your reputation in England is one of
some [ __ ] make you listen muck
out the OED I'm sorry don't want any
money days when I put this muck out
there I'm I'm sorry I'm off let me go
free Mike if I could certainly counter
with a counter-puncher leo defending my
old profession what I would say is that
the British papers they love to build
people up they love to knock him down
and they love a redemption story as well
they love them coming back so it's
it's like being a I always felt like
you're in a in a prize fight every day
you know you're in a rough-and-tumble
newsroom recovering rough stories rough
people and it was you know you had to be
tough to do it but it reminded me of
being in a fight half the time it's so
interesting
no so I mean they love that here in
America to not like English idolize use
idolization is such a massive [ __ ]
following in England and those um UK
neighborhood idolizing this they have
great things idolize you know I mean
they they have the great the English
warriors and stuff that they have the
guys on RA they have the crepe or all
those guys they make those guys into
legend from Cloyd they're almost
superheroes God's decree twins that my
excited there were gangsters from
Eastern to London they shouldn't really
have been heroes to anybody and yet now
still after they long after they both
died the Kray twins they're revered in
many parts of East London certainly
because they you know they had a hold
over their people where they they looked
after the women and the kids and
everything else they only fought their
own as they put it there was a kind of
honor amongst thieves at the rate Reggie
Kray when I was in prison you did yeah
and he wrote back to you yeah he wrote
me first Wow
what did you discuss with her um he has
told me about his life and I was
discussing what I was doing here and how
I feel about being here what am i doing
I get out and when I came out so that
was when you're in prison yeah so when I
came out to prison I was I was I was
fighting somewhere I think it was Judy's
friends I was coming off the fight
somebody the big fight and I gave my
respects tie with the visit his family
and I was talking kindly about them and
they almost set me out of the country
back to America well yeah I mean he was
you know I had some dealings with him
you did they were tough guys I mean
they'd you know the the 60s in a prism
of such a sweet man he was very well
behaved Britain yeah and they both were
here I mean Ronnie his brother was in
Broadmoor which was more of a
psychiatric prison he ran he was really
out there yeah he was slightly matter
I'd say reg was in a conventional prison
wasn't he yes Parkhurst and there made
sort of thing but they they were you
know fascinating parts of in
Fogell they were folk heroes to many
people in the Richardson's I was a Jaa's
in a restaurant Mike about three years
ago with some old village friends and
this guy came to our table immaculate in
a smart suit and beard and everything
came over and introduced himself to me I
thank God I was friendly cset he said
mr. Morgan I wonder if I think he said
my wife would like to have a photograph
but I said of course I probably did all
that and then you had a little chat and
he walked off and the maitre d of the
restaurant came over and said do you
know that is I went no he said that's
Charlie Richardson they're from the
Richardson gang oh they were the rival
gang that the Kray that are the crazy
lady Lindy chakram and they were killing
a lot of people so I was very glad I was
friendly to it dad kill you you say I'm
not afraid of you I'm not afraid of you
did kill you you're not afraid of me
boom do you think there's something to
it being an older an older section of
the world you know then America America
is very young I feel like there's not
much the identity gets so blurred
sometimes so many countries before with
England well the city is taking
different inhabitant that in question
seemed in America right America is a
reputation worldwide of being very
violent country uh-huh particularly with
the guns and everything else and I
always say to people even though I've
been I've campaigned against the guns to
try but some control on it but I always
say you have to understand America is a
very young country and the Britain when
it was a young country was constantly at
war with people
Costin everyone had a gun in the rise of
Britain same with Germany same with
Japan and Australia so a lot of
countries that used to have a lot of
guns but our older countries I think you
know eventually came to a more peaceful
scenario with a with their countries and
their people America still seems to me
is it it's a fantastic country in so
many ways but absolutely it's being we
still feared riveting but you fear
driven and I think a lot of paranoia in
America I think a lot of medication is
part of the problem 80% of the world's
painkillers are taken in America
fragrance to disagree you have all the
opioid crisis you have everything and
you
have this this gun culture which doesn't
seem strange to Americans but God it
seems strange to everybody else I mean
you know I was interesting I mean for
example in Britain we have were fifth of
the size of America and in Britain we
have thirty two gun deaths a year on
average America will have 880 people
today and tomorrow and the next day
32,000 a year
another 70,000 get hit by gunfire but
don't die they're saved by surgeons and
I always say look it's the strange thing
I got my sister my son's here and one of
them he's six foot one six four two long
hair beard everything right here and I
tried to give him a non-alcoholic beer
at Gladstone's in Malibu right the
restaurant this is a couple of years ago
and and they wouldn't serve him a
non-alcoholic beer without ID I said
it's non-alcoholic there when it has no
point naught naught 1 percent alcohol
right we're not allowed to give him a
non-alcoholic beer the same month up in
Arizona 8 year old girl was at a gun
range called bullets and burgers and she
was being taught how to fire guns for
her birthday party and this former
Marine was teaching her and the parents
were videoing this with their phone and
you see it take ever bigger more
powerful guns and eventually he gives
her a boozy submachine gun and eight
year old kid and she goes pop pop and
then the everything goes nuts the video
gives up because she lost control and
she shot the guy in the head the marina
killed him and to me these two things
happening in the space of a month yeah a
6-foot 2 inch 23 year old kid guy can't
get a non-alcoholic beer cuz he hasn't
got his ID on him and an 8 year old girl
could fire an Uzi machine gun and kill
somebody legally I know that's [ __ ]
crazy but you have to look at how we
look in this country too you know we
have our young young daughters out here
we have a son there's animals out here
they're disrespectful an old I hate [ __ ]
you yes do whatever he wants to your
daughter your son [ __ ] you do it do what
you wanna do you call a cop the cops
dinner we go to court he didn't he'd
done that in two years said [ __ ] you
touchy this is not nothing spirit he's
just kidding to you
well then again have you harassed he
drives and faint what do you want her to
do how does he defend herself
I think I'm not at all saying America
has to give up all his guns I understand
there are so many guns out there that
people want to defend themselves but I
do think there ought to be in my opinion
taking all the school shootings right
these mass shootings are gone our
schools tend to be slightly unhinged
kids 1920-21
you know something wrong with hurricane
extra might overmedicated playing these
video games twenty hours a day and so on
and they have such easy legal access to
semi-automatic rifles yeah and it's that
where I think come on America well I
think you gathered you're empowering
these kids to commit mass there too you
know what they don't say a lot of
parents teach their children how to
shoot I'm supportive of that my
brother's a British Army colonel right
is in Afghanistan right now serving with
Americans right in in Kabul
I don't having a problem intrinsically
with guns to hunt to do sports shooting
even in America to defend yourself I get
that argument I do have a problem in
nineteen year old nut job kids getting
AR 15 shooting up schools
yes I found sir Americans big problems I
feel you don't want to be humiliated we
don't want to be embarrassed in front
anyone yeah BCF what I would say Mike is
there is a difference in Britain we have
lots of fights right yeah lots of people
get into fights on a pub on a Friday
night they're getting a fight the
difference here is a lot of little
fights very quickly become a gun sheet
you know a little argument a dispute
people crashing into each other by
mistake and then outcome the gun so
before you know it it's all over and
people are dead in Britain that doesn't
happen because they don't have the tools
to kill each other we have a knife
problem but it's nowhere near as big as
the gun well no island they don't give a
damn right yeah well shoot you here in
Ireland well they got you got gang issue
with guns in Ireland in England in
England we had a mass shooting in 1996
16 schoolchildren very similar the Sandy
Hook got killed and we banned basically
all guns from civilian use and that's
why we have we haven't had a school
shooting since Sandy Hook happened in
two
than 12 was on air at CNN and 20 kids
got killed nothing got done to stop it
happening again there have been 250
school shootings since Sandy Hook now as
a parent you're a parent right
absolutely I'm a parent if you're a
parent but parents should be looking at
this going come on this is our kids
should not be going to old worrying
about me I'm doing America in America we
teach our kids you don't take no [ __ ]
from no riding right you know me but I
feel too big you get something for them
now that's what how taught if he's too
big you get then you get your gun you
get your knife you get your back that's
how we talk what do you think is up what
I think about that I think that is
really um premise primitive thinking how
do you change the thinking excuse me
how do you change the thinking by
teaching them how to love that gentleman
going walking with my child show me the
person that you have that indication and
showing them we don't need to do this
people like you can change thinking yeah
with great respect to myself when I was
a CNN you know a British guy sounding
like George the third is not gonna be
the best person to make Americans give
up their guns Mike Tyson couldn't make
people change their mind about the
aggression and the violence that so many
people feel definitely in America you
know I wanna know what he hate about
himself so much that he wants to kill
that guy
right you know it was about him that he
hates about him something with that guy
dead right cuz that's what it always
comes down to it's how much pain that
that individual is in yeah you know yeah
and we don't approach that at all in
America we don't have mental health AC
but I argue this every country has
mental health problems right Britain has
lots of mental health problems what you
have to do is stop the people that are
on that spectrum of mental illness or
have problems from easy access to
killing machines that's easy I mean that
should be in what is easy to do but it
has to be a will to do it right in
America there's no will politically yeah
NRA and others to do anything at all so
nothing ever gets done and most
countries when we look at New Zealand
right New Zealand had this appalling
mass shooting at the moss
yeah a few weeks ago and within two
weeks they had banned all semi-automatic
rifles and guns right gone done they've
had their massacre they're not having
another one or they're gonna make it
incredibly difficult to do that I don't
think anyone needs a semi-automatic only
when you change this mentality in
America they're afraid to get beat up in
front of their children and why yeah I
get it you have to change I'm afraid for
you to smack me and I can't you're too
strong for me to fight you back or do
anything and you disrespect me and my
children away well how did she change
because you check use me huh you've
changed over the years right yeah you
you went from that kid when you were 13
and being arrested all the time of
fighting with time and everything you
became this guy so how did you do that
because I find that really interesting
how you
I don't know evolved um I had good
friends I had um I had a good guy and
whatever and good support system so to
speak
right hit hit absolute rock bottom
absolutely and that guy had to disappear
that guy was totally too tough for my
existence and do you remember a moment
Mike when you thought I need to change
do you remember what that moment was no
I never um it was never needed the
chamber as always I had to change it I
was gonna die we never need to change
this was never it was never because hey
Mike this is that this is our man a
behavior I'm dealing with my life I was
dealing with no way I could exist
continuing on but a lot of people in
America think have that kind of anger
and despair about the life they're
leaving but they also they get brought
up in angry and aggressive environments
and they have firearms or whatever it
may be it's a it's a dangerous cocktail
well Sammy do our kids are terrifying
and we're creating a generation of anger
anxious we're and kids who then they're
killing themselves yeah there's getting
sucked into depression and heavy
medication they're committing mass
murder in some cases and I've got a
theory about this we just got to in this
battle with mental health don't talk
about mental health there's mental
illness and there should be mental
strength how do you we teach kids every
day in school how
be good at maths or how to be good at
inner sciences or any of these things we
should be teaching mental strength and
resilience how do you deal with life
yeah you know how absolutely into
perspective from what degree do we deal
with life you have to look from what
level of degree right we deal from life
you know me uh what do you get one of
those guys um those Swami's might think
life is a different perspective from a
different dimension you know I mean I
think everyone get life different from
from where we we look at it from a
different completely and listen my
upbringing in a little leafy village in
the South of England compared to your
upbringing right completely different
however however the the similarities are
everybody has to face [ __ ] at some stage
yeah right you're gonna lose loved ones
that you care desperately about you're
gonna have things go wrong in your life
you're gonna get fired you're gonna get
your things gonna happen we lose this is
interesting that we go to no we lose
those loved ones in your life what do
you think even though we continue to
live my life I lost a daughter for years
daughter a few years ago right I
remember but dig um I think I know when
this is over I'm gonna be with her yeah
and we be together I but I believe that
my father died when I was one for
example and a lot of people have that
kind of thing in their lives no but my
stepfather came along and took on two
kids you know young boys in his mid-20s
and them and he's you know my dad and
every year that goes by when I think
about what he did and the sacrifice he
made my you know love and feelings for
him strengthened he imagined being 21
think on that carry
right I mean amazing you know when I
think about my smile dastan there is
he's 26 you know he's the same age my
dad was we came and scooped up two kids
and and this you know the people do
extraordinary things don't they but I
think that I try and teach my son's just
life is there's a whole rocky thing
isn't it life really is about it's not
about how hard you can hit right anyone
can punch something not as well as you
know it's how many times you get up when
you get here and you get knocked down
and you're in a bad place
can you get up and get on the one thing
I think I've always looking back at my
career
my life is when I've been dealt blows
I've always tried to write okay that's
just now you're gonna get up and get
going again and I just don't think
enough kids these days get told this and
she taught it this is how you this is
how you become more resilient this is
how you deal with crap in your life this
is how you deal with stuff when it goes
wrong and then think you know I hate
things like a school now participation
prizes for everybody oh no that's not
right that's not their life isn't about
everyone wins and everyone gets a
birthday surprise right life's about
people winning and losing and dealing
with understand competition competition
isn't that like I'm better than you
competition is that eateth when we get
mature we won't give in and I decide
this struggle yeah right and also right
until you lose you don't know the joy of
winning yeah you can win win win but
when you lose then the next time you win
it means more look at Tiger Woods right
we were talking about this before we get
yeah Tiger Woods no nobody has had the
highs and lows of that guy's hat right
not even you might with respect could
probably compare its career-wise to what
went on with Tiger Woods with the number
one golfer arguably in history right and
he's a black golfer in a whites pool who
transformed it completely yeah build a
generation of kids to come through and
be athletes and everything amazing
trailblazer and then it all goes
horribly wrong he's hit by scandal after
scandal his body collapses he's number
1199 in the world 18 months ago he's
done he's finished there's a brilliant
video clip of Tiger Woods being shown
people trolling him in Agrius other
sport is done he's Danny's finish and
Tigers watching all this or I never win
again never win again he's finished and
he shouldn't have won again but the only
person in the end who believed he could
win again was Tiger yet and he won the
Masters and it was an amazing moment of
not even Redemption this was revenge
this was you lot can suck it because I
just give you wrong and you had a little
you got a picture out there and it's
Frank Sinatra and it says the best
revenge is massive success - it's so
true right right absolutely yeah
whatever anyone says you know
I remember watching you might when I
when you first came on the scene I've
never seen anything like it
I never have since you were the most
ferocious incredible fighter I've ever
watched it was the most exhilarating
exciting thing to watch you in those
black shorts getting in that wring your
neck twitching even I thousands of miles
away in England I was collapsing in fear
and I don't I don't go Benny one knee
and I remember it like the Michael
Spinks fight when he's just staring at
you and you're thinking Pink's he's um
beat right he should be like ready for
this and his legs start to waffle and
the whole things over before you get
near him and I remember thinking this
guy no one's ever gonna beat this guy
and then you got hit by your problems
you got hit by a few blows on and off in
the ring out of the ring and you had to
somehow deal with that and for tops
sportsman who's been completely
unbeatable that's tough it's a hard
thing isn't it
no because their life here since then
well yeah you can be you know and in
sports you know everyone's beating this
suppose every you know we're designed to
be beating this foot what we're gonna do
after that because that's a small
increment of our life what are we gonna
do after that
wha we're gonna give up because did you
believe this is the best moment of our
life and we no longer have it because we
don't possess that crown it calls us
this I don't know a champion a king
whatever you are we have to continue to
go on improving I felt that human beings
what was it what was the greatest moment
for you of your career if I could replay
one for you now what would you choose I
don't know when I was 16 I went and
fought this man and Boston Massachusetts
he was I was 1516 128 he beat me but was
really close
hey that was for my best fight then and
that's the one you that's the one you'd
remember yeah that's awesome it's
fascinating because because it told you
that you you have what it took yeah well
maybe would give me a standing ovation
love that feeling yeah because I lied
about my age anybody who I was and I got
Nooh I lied they say you're 15 because
you know everybody I was on the stage
and I was like you know the young guy
it's one of the Jun national
championships why they were throw the
garland 16 15 years old this guy
I will fight them here I was in laughs
are you turning professional but he was
just old and challenging fighting this
more no for the guy I know it was just
as a while I was a great fighter with a
standing ovation but he won and I
thought I won by a while I was just my
great performance I gave it all that
she's not there's no facility so you
choose a moment that nobody I bet no
Mike Tyson fan in the world would have
thought I've ever thought that would be
the moment you to chose it's an amazing
answer yeah and yet I can see as you
relive it why that meant so much to you
I cried all the way home you did from
Boston in New York really yeah it's not
amazing it's amazing
those Rhode Island's raw talent in New
York I cried all the way home
what happened to that guide you know the
guy you've know I saw him before I
thought him again at a professional that
I must had two amateur fights to
professionals like Bernie he had turned
professional he didn't do well in
profession as I saw him I gave him a hug
and I was just always so clean and pure
and I just um I gave my hugs I smiley
had liquor on his breath mmm you know
and he went a different way in life was
that experience that he gave me made me
a better individual amazing Wow I never
forget him do you remember his name
alone beanie bean even remember that
it's not amazing that's such an amazing
story dude we fired it too fascinating
man I was doing this as a kid everything
that was 14 13 so I ever did no brakes
and all I never did I live with Custer
so we have a whole perspective was about
fighting the concept of fighting the
fact the fact is of fighting do you ever
think what would have happened to you if
you'd never met cus no because it was
ordained by God for me to meet him me
think what would have happened is
incidentally that means nothing it
doesn't exist there's what I've
interviewed you before be saying that
the thing the absolute thing he
instilled in you was was discipline that
ever everything with him was about
discipline everything they do were to do
what I hated to do but do it like I love
it
[Music]
did you hate it or did you hate Trina
who love who really learning training
every for every day then I don't care
how much of the killer you are the ring
me in the smiling doing some swamp
Islands kicking your ass and you're
frustrated almost dropping you get my
full moon he almost drops you so you got
to keep your cool and I get mad and this
is its complex boy I remember asking
Freddie Roach I went up to his gym man
and I was Freddie woman's the onion have
you ever been scared you know when
you've been doing a session with
somebody and he laughed he went well
there was a time when Mike came in and
he was in a really bad mood and things
got pretty pretty lively in the ring I
can't believe I was that guy no idea
what the guys they had scary stories in
me and my sound guy you know does this
seem like another person to you know um
do you ever feel that might not ever get
involved in a situation where suddenly
you feel the old feelings no I know who
that guy was though you know before I
didn't understand that guy know that guy
was the guys he's afraid
you know he's insecure you have to love
him people know they he's really very
loved when was the last time you
actually hit someone an anger Wow okay
remember it happened I'm in California
no must have been I had a reporter I was
coming back from England and I had a
reporter and I'm I was high - I just did
some cocaine right before I got on the
plane from England and soon that was and
I was still hiding in the resin so that
video sleep booms I dropped so I'm
irritated going this guy's filming me
and then I caught the guy yeah and now I
see the guy at the airport all the time
we always talk he's a good friend we
went to the zoo so really 25 some money
and so we're cool and we're friends
I thought he doesn't take your picture
without
I really have a great very respect for
him now and that was the last time was a
few years ago right yeah I have my
children with my wife from a mother lode
now that pig oh so embarrassed you know
but that's quite a few years ago right
yes so you've learned real
self-discipline about I learnt that um
that I was that guy one time and I need
to been struck a lot of times too it's
just that I had the distinct Matai
protected me and stuff but I understand
that we all make mistakes in life and we
just hit learning and it's almost over I
was a young kid I was heavyweight champ
Muhammad Sharma too long and boomer I'm
52 it's almost over with time go what
did I actually learn how did I get here
what's my purpose for gee what do you
say to your kids about life but it
wasn't what advice to give them excuse
me
what do you say to your kids about life
I explained to them they get I don't
like what they put in life you know you
have to go in the life with a great deal
of dignity honor and respect but a great
deal of determination as well you know
and I try to explain that to them but
it's so difficult for me to explain that
to him when these guys in a nice little
match and the house is cleaned they got
to do the maid and I say to myself what
the [ __ ] am I trying to say because
that's not even existed
didn't even believe that they still
attack me and strike me they don't think
I'm not a tough guy and sometimes I
think because of some of my success in
what I've done in life I think I stole
it from my kids they can't see the
reality of where I came from
they grandmother and grandfather was
tempting prostitutes and they lived in a
very dark fights life and these kids
live in the light you know and I call
that elevation hmm evolution excuse me
the evolution you know I get it
completely it's a different world isn't
it yes it's a different world exactly
the different world sometimes my whole
life I thought I was a stick you know me
[ __ ] the god of the savages look
where I came from I hate feel sorry for
myself
head shifts my shooter cuz I was always
poor I was an educator I'm
to watch me rain and all that stuff and
I found that I'm a little scary boy and
that no tough guy were you ever scared
in the ring
pom petrified really yeah I was just
just a plain fight I was always
petrified even though you'll be first
pro fight my first pro fight I remember
feeling the fight when they match it
that's the guy you fighting so I went
outside I don't know to go for a walk I
was getting ready to get on a plane
train and I come back I was so scared
and even at your peak when you were the
world everywhere job yeah exactly
you have to have can't imagine
participating in the kind of combat
sport without it isn't that interesting
ice fascinating to me cuz I can't
imagine but I've watched you in the ring
I knew fear from a different perspective
and no fear from my mother and father
not being respected for my father being
a wrestler for me it's being a street
person living in [ __ ] abandoned
buildings not having food so I knew it
you know fear wasn't stuff night and I
knew what it was like to be bullied by
people and I know what it was like to be
afraid but enable tough guys and he's
put that darkness with me once curse
helped me with others part of it
fascinating I went to see Mike's one-man
show in Vegas took my three sons and we
sat in a booth and and it was such a
surprising show because it wasn't about
boxing it already is about life and you
were there you had your white suit at
this lovely gospel choir you had it was
a trip first one it was fight got
involved it was bossy I loved it I loved
the simplicity of it and you're just
telling a story and it was such an a
really inspiring story because you
didn't make it all about
look at me knocking people out I mean we
did come away thinking Brad Pitt's very
lucky to be alive yes yeah we did come
away with but no it's really it was very
interesting to me I've interviewed you a
number of times over the years and
always found you got such a complexity
of layers about you as a human being
very you a very complex character and
yet that makes you a fascinating person
to interview yeah because you have such
a good perspective on so many things
because you've been through such dark
places as well as good stuff yeah
and that's most people don't get to some
of the places you've been to they can't
understand what that is like that's why
in a way I think some of these big
debates America is now having it'll mean
people like you that can have a real
affect and influence of people because
they look at you and they relate to you
in a way they would never relate to
someone like me you really think so
I do hear me I do yeah it's because you
were the epitome of a warrior you know
with your ferocity and your just your
attitude and your energy and everything
you brought into the ring man for you to
then talk about how you felt fear in the
ring and then I mean Mike I mean let me
just acknowledge dude for you to wrap up
and understand that all of your fear you
gathered from when you were a little kid
and you brought all of that with you
into the ring man for you to be able to
articulate that it transforms people
because people go oh [ __ ] I'm not alone
I'm [ __ ] terrified and I'm not alone
and Mike Tyson a God among men has felt
fear and feels fear it's powerful man
yeah it's powerful and that's why you
know that's why this show is is so
[ __ ] important what we're doing then
have Pearce come on have these people
come on and we talk about life how do we
teach our kids you know that even in
this life where all of these resources
are provided for you you still need to
have grit and tenacity and you still
need to understand that life is not all
[ __ ] butterflies and cupcakes and
you're not supposed to be happy all the
time nobody is but that's the thing I
think the problem that kids have they
have two things I think one is the
Instagram phenomenon
yeah where every kids on Instagram and
all this thing all the time is a life
they would love Rowe and they see
perfect images and perfect pictures
everything is airbrushed everything is
cleanse to show perfection an
unobtainable perfection even the
supermodels can't look as good whereas
these pictures right and so you're
chasing an impossible dream it's not the
conventional American dream which is
achievable which is if you work really
hard and have a passion for something
you have a you can succeed in this
country if a good chance
this isn't unobtainable dream you're
never gonna look as perfect as these
people are pretending to be so you have
a pretense around address which is
damaging and secondly I think the kids
you know they're always on them I've got
a seven-year-old girl as well and I got
three much bigger boys but they're all
on their phones over time I'm on my
phone all the time you know we all do it
but of course I I was interviewed by dr.
Phil for his podcast recently we were
talking about why is it that kids are so
much more anxious generally about the
world you know and about stuff was going
on and he made a really interesting
point that of course what technology is
done is it's brought the world to
people's phones so in the old days if
something happened now in Chicago or
Seattle right you know an alligator
killed somebody or something right we
wouldn't know about it here right you
wouldn't know that happened right now
you're gonna see a video of this
alligator eating a guy yeah and you're
gonna see it within 20 minutes right and
then they had the foot in the leg right
and you're gonna see it happening within
15 minutes right right so there you go
so we would never have known that even
hot Road so now if you're on Twitter all
day or Facebook you just think the
entire world's going completely nuts
when in fact as I say the kids here's
the truth it's the safest time to ever
be alive in recorded history fewer
people are being killed than ever
recorded before right it's the
healthiest time to ever be alive
statistically we're living much longer
than we used to and we're fighting many
more diseases more successfully now
right it is you know in almost every way
of measuring life is less poverty than
there's ever been in the history of
planet Earth was this from Egypt and
Egypt the height of media business life
expense ecstasy was I'm 35 years old
right 35 you look amazing 35 years old
crazy and even increased
time is 24 years yes here's the good
news
right the planets a pretty good place
right now there are fewer Wars and
they've ever been historically you're
gonna live long do you know listen I was
just telling one like if a gay man is
going for a walk back in you know me um
the dark ages so to speak you go forward
who and boom is if you see 60,000 people
the foreign army at your door right good
luck fam it's different now ready to
just burn the [ __ ] village to the
ground
yeah and yet you see this generation
think it's the world I know and we have
no need to know that an alligator killed
like it does us no good none for our
safety over our understanding of the
world
I agreed you hundred percent but know
what since the beginning of time we were
told that we need that fine knowledge
information since the beginning that
time we now have to Malaysian absolutely
I say travel fine you learn well we get
a hit of dopamine and serotonin when we
learn something new because that's how
our brain works because every time it
wants to reward us every time we do
something new that it hasn't seen or
experienced before so when you're
looking through your Instagram feed
you're seeing a new thing every second
and you're just getting hits of that
so listen yes for instance I normally
watch police I'm pulling over people on
the rats and people and people being
disrespectful to police how did that
stuff and then I started I saw um
pictures me fighting some and so I
started looking at me and I've seen
every day I said look at me and every
day every other day they had a new story
of me about me from somebody I don't
even know they don't even know mean he
tells people stories about me you know
for like an hour put together story
telling Google story about me so I'm
fine like so much force information
about me with actual facts about me just
blowing my mind
and it gets to the stage where even if
you are saying it people won't believe
that because they've already been told
that's not true so the truth
is getting killed out there you know
Facebook and all these companies are
allowing so much fake news genuine fake
news to be spread and it's dangerous
it's really bad
because um I think what they looking for
is just a spectacular lism you know I
mean yeah clickbait was what you said
it's the gratification that comes from
the hid and we're now in a world where
every everyone wants it instantly it's
why people's patience for anything is
gone you know my favorite sport is
cricket
and the reason we love it so much as
Americans just don't understand why we
would like a sport where you can play
five matches of five days each and at
the end of it the score might be zero
zero and we did it deliberately to
confound Americans and make sure that
you never played it so you could never
beat a set of people which is what you
would do yeah prefer the fact that
Americans like to have your own sports
where you call yourselves the world
champ hey listen even though you're
through the entrance America's the
greatest still in inventions yes yes but
you're also the best they're the best
thing you do Mike you invent this Dylan
you create sports and then you declare
yourselves world champ yes even though
no other country is allowed to enter I
admire that
well the Jaguars might be coming to
London so yeah I saw that
well how do you God so as a journalist I
mean what's your take on fake news in
this phenomenon I mean it's really
started in the last what five years
I think the orbit was the Trump yeah I
think the internet or the Trump is come
along that trumps what he's always been
he's a bullshitter right of course
yes somebody that spent his entire life
selling buildings talking [ __ ] starts he
starts off saying this building's worth
150 million
he knows privately he wants a hundred
someone says don't be ridiculous is
worth 40 and they settle on 90 right and
everyone's happy right he's taking that
same mentality to the White House now
some of the stuff he does I think is is
good and is working some of it I wish
he'd stop being so petty and pathetic in
some ways I'm president
but ultimately Trump will be judged on
his actions on his words and you know I
suspect he might get reelected how do
you know oh no and the civilization of
truck man this is just a goddess on fire
yeah and it's only consistencies he's on
fire there I wasn't necessarily asking
about him as much thinking about fake
news I don't blame Trump for that I
think he's okay he's come along at a
time where this is sort of he's these
events to blame wrote and Facebook and
these companies all of which I use as a
consumer they have not been strong
enough and tough enough and cracking
down on fake news from Trump for better
or worse he lets you know what he's
thinking in real time you can't help
right he's telling you what he's saying
some of his ugly some of it is good I
think he's a fascinating political
animal need to talk the treasured he's
taking his message to social media which
allows him to talk directly to the
public and bypass everybody right really
pisses yeah I know he doesn't know he's
totally non-conventional and he is what
he is and down in the middle America I
go there a lot they love Trump for all
the reasons that the coasts don't like
him right they love Trump I love him
sticking it to the media they love him
sticking it right defending himself but
you know if you read the art of the deal
his book it's all in there yeah there's
nothing Trump is doing now which is any
difference of a Trump in that book this
is the guy he's always been absolutely
that's why you won you know it's still a
shame what interrupt supports Mike
Tyson's one of those things yeah you
know I mean that's pretty weird man what
he loves boxes because I did the severly
apprentice season one with him and I was
in there with Lennox Lewis and Tito
Ortiz so I know if this podcast and I
ended up winning it I'm knocked out
Lennox in the semi Lennox if you're
watching not you out he's watching
Lennox his last words to me before we
went in for the final border he said he
said I'm gonna get this you say cuz
Donald Trump loves boxers I went mate
I'm not going you out what do you think
of the mauler report well it's easy
this was designed to investigate Russian
collusion right so the whole point of
the Muller investigation was that
everyone kept saying Trump colluded with
the Russian row to fix the election so
he's a fake president who shouldn't be
there the mullah reports come back and
it's completely exonerated Trump of any
collusion not only Trump but any of his
campaign team it's also exonerated any
American there's no evidence of any
American whatsoever actively colluding
with the Russians to fix the election
there are I think bigger questions to
answer about the obstruction of justice
stuff but on that I would simply take
the bigger picture
this is Trump basically reacting badly
to fake allegations of collusion right
and so if you take away the fake
allegation of collusion you have none of
his erratic angry behavior which is now
being categorized as obstruction it's
like chicken and the egg you know there
is no chicken I the Muller report is if
you imagine that as the as the
overarching thing there's no obstruction
without the allegation of fake collusion
which turned out to be fake so I've not
sympathy for Trump on this I think that
he he was falsely accused of colluding
with the Russians and it was they were
saying it D legitimized his election win
and he took it very badly I think all
the behavior that they're now saying was
obstructing justice came out of him
feeling pissed off quite rightly the
cable news was 24/7 pounding him for
collusion which in the end was proven
not to have happened so I've got
sympathy for him on it but you know
they're out to get him and yeah I'm not
sure it's a clever so you're on a wire
and burn and I think it's a it's a
mistake by the Democrats in particular
because I think it will help get Trump
reelected i dude I'm telling people
myself Pierce I'm like man he's gonna
get reelected dude you can't you can't
keep hammering a guy like him without
people who support him feeling even more
strongly they want to separate so
actually it empowers his base and I
think the Democrats don't have a
candidate yet they can beat it and I'd
be very instead who they put up against
him because you need someone
gonna be very tough and I don't see who
that person is is it would be like
putting someone up to fight Mike in his
prime right who was that person everyone
thought it was someone like Michael
Spinks and he you know he collapsed in
front of you so who is this person that
can beat Trump it's all very well
screaming about him yeah saying what a
monster he is rather some stage in 2020
and he's coming up fast
really bad eight C months right real
fast and Trump is already amazing
there's nothing close no one even close
yet no hey let's look at Ron when he's
young well we did Pepsi commercials all
right the Trump and Pepsi commercials
coming back this is when he was a young
guy the memory was young here I do I do
he was very you know he was a very
instant character trouble me for 30 40
years he's been in my news isn't easy
it's a big figure it's not like he
suddenly came along everyone knew who
Trump was I just ever imagined he could
become president but I I thought he
could at the moment he said he was
running I had told people you watch this
I wrote this for your fight yeah we love
we do a lot of commercial we got a bomb
back then do it it's [ __ ] cool did
you speak to him after he won have you
seen him since no no no I think talked
about this leaping yeah II think so yeah
let's talk about where I come from in
England obviously this is illegal you
know you can do this yeah break it the
way that you are and yeah I've watched
the way in California things have gone
and it appears on the face of it have
been very successful and whether you
call it recreational or medicinal people
who are using cannabis recreationally
are using it to medicate some issue that
they're dealing with people self
medicate with alcohol drink themselves
into definitely creating our aim
Britain okay you know when people go to
aim right you've written you a your
[ __ ] [ __ ] we drink an awful lot and
yet the same people that drink drink
drink oh well we couldn't possibly
legalize cannabis I might trust me you
should be on cannabis not how God yeah
because that's doing a lot worse for you
than cannabis would absolutely you know
it it's you know from the medicinal side
it interacts with our endocannabinoid
system you know I'm sure you know all
about that very familiar with it yeah I
believe that you are I did a show on
this with yeah - Sanjay Gupta exactly
exactly she tried it on that I figured
what about you Alec drugs you haven't
experienced I have no choice sucker than
ever everyone
oh man has changed my whole life really
yeah no and I did a thing where I was
like people ten years old before but
listen right the fact is that I'm I did
this to explain to him come on please
total who told ancient medicine
well cannabis is open the door for a lot
of these plant medicines that are now
beginning to emerge across America Mike
did it yes yes it was inconceivable so
intergalactic you know for instance I
yeah I'm in the skies I'm just I die you
take it I inhaled it exhale and I
actually died there's an ego death you
know I'm afraid I've died well you feel
like you're dead no I am dead I don't
exist I'm I said I have nobody have no
legs it's just my my entity I'm just I'm
just and I don't know what's going on
I'm scared and I wanted power this last
time I took it probably two weeks ago so
think I wanted power and I got so much
power I just integrate it so much so if
I feel comfortable about you being
empowered by by towed stuff around like
you you're feeling powerful you know
could be dangerous yeah it could be but
it wasn't when I was finished I was in
love with love brilliant yeah I was in
love with love I realized that
everything I wanted was out of fear and
that it was it was something worthy of
prayer than wasn't me it was and then we
know it is Kaaba was the big entity and
entity and it was only I only wanted the
worship to it how many times have you
been properly in love in your life I
have no idea
properly in love like you know
considering myself yeah my whole life
apart from you I mean other people I
don't know it's so easy for me to fall
in love I fall in love with a pigeon you
love your picture yes how many of you
still call the pigeons yeah how many Joe
well I've had a couple of thousand I'm
probably gonna I probably got a thousand
now 15 what is it you love about pigeon
let's see um my childhood the first time
I began to a scuffle was over a pigeon
why
somebody took my pigeon and ripped his
head off really yeah so [ __ ] up there
was a bunch of kitd coming around
neighbors they heard that I had I had
robbed the house and a half some money
so I wouldn't bought some pigeons I was
a penny pincher fancier so um I will put
my hit the pigeons all these guys one
guy that told my brother he told some
other guy said he came to the
neighborhood stole my pigeons and I was
fighting them so I got on my berth back
with the guys snuck one of my brothers
in his jacket I ran and someone said
Mike he has one of your birds and so I
went to catch my second and my third
please that [ __ ] you you want this bird
you sad [ __ ] he ripped the bird's head
off did bring my friends to fight him
right and I fought on this first never
fought or won the fight
Wow that was the time yeah cuz the guy
killed your pigeon big time yeah firstly
we have a fighter try to fight somebody
when you're with your pigeons now what
does it bring you what you get out of it
I don't know take me back to my
childhood in what way they have to take
care of them and protect them because of
what happened to that pigeon that time
somebody I take them was stealing for me
it's crazy yeah that's amazing it's
crazy
you feel like a collective protection
thing yeah you want to take care of them
yeah I've known people who have done
people off the roof for their painting
like for stories of the roof yeah that's
the kind of where we come from you still
are [ __ ] will kill you we hurt you real
bad you know it's still from anybody
again that's just a mindset when I could
have gave him a [ __ ] couple of
pigeons we had hundreds of them you know
you're getting me once a bird from that
would give it to him now do they have
characteristics oh yeah a lot different
than the same they're all different
yeah all different like humans yeah
there's nothing to say nothing
did you get some bitter aggressive and
somebody's recive yeah that's
interesting it's birthday like people
when you watch them it's a couple of
hundred men on this side of the roof
that little box is probably 12 foot 12
inches the boxes and of course a couple
hundred boxes across the wall and you
watch them intact seven i'ma cry so I'm
standing on top of the box every tearing
everything another pigeon is starting
trouble messing with other guys women
now the guy comes in a fight and they go
back to his box he's just a bunch of
[ __ ] going so crazy and she talked to
her huh you talk to them yeah yeah I
said I could talk to him I talk to him
what do you say well items you know stop
[ __ ] with that once he goes over them
beats up on the young bird you know it's
just a bunch of stuff it's fascinating
it's awesome it's like a little mini
it's the number fight and make love and
cheetah on each other yeah let's complex
like human yeah it's like a man they
might she he has a baby in this box and
he got eggs in this box he's spent his
time here there was his wife's cousin
here he gets on the eggs there's crazy
that's so funny what do you make of the
the fight game at the moment I don't
know I haven't looked at it too much you
know they had a really good exciting
fight with Tyson Fury and yeah warrior
on what's a Wilder yeah so that's
bringing a heavyweight boxing back
in this generation because that was
really exciting what do you make your
Tyson figures is a gypsy at heart you
know what does that mean that kind of
not open empty kept faith or know
whether there was a trap there travel a
traveling community so they don't have
any fixed place they travel around in
caravans they set up homes wherever they
go for a few weeks a few months and
they're very they keep amongst
themselves they're very tough a lot of
the bare-knuckle fighting is done by but
like I've been very successful
businessman yeah yeah yeah they haven't
been totally isolated to death their
form of life no no no no not at all but
they you know they people some bay badly
and give them a bad name many others I
think you're very decent people
and I've met quite a few travelers in my
life they have a very diverse Civic out
of life and they have they have the the
mystic lifestyle yeah you know leaving
after life as well yeah hey I really
like him he's like really um know what
he is he's really a breath of fresh air
yeah you know just really he's really
clean it's really he really looks clean
he's a clean guy that clean fight a good
punt he's just you know yes what's the
best friend can someone like that would
would anyone as clean as that have
beaten Tyson at his peak I don't know
you know no my Eagle said nobody would
beat you but you look at him no but you
know he it looks beautiful you know he
looks like a fighter you know he'd look
like he was born to do what he have to
do he needs more experience of course
but they had come in life you know yeah
we watched we went to the stable Center
watched lemon chenko the other night oh
he musta gave you a show huh wow that
guy who did he fight he fought a British
guy called Anthony crawler who's NASA
who has won titles you know this guy's
won I must have been out of his League
it was like several leagues yeah
watching that girl limit sink you like a
pile a plate then yeah either ballet
there he's extraordinary extraordinary I
thought one of the best I've ever seen
see now I'm looking for a young guy that
we have from our community from
Baltimore
Devante Javonte Davis javante Davis is
my son loves ya ya name Devante David
here and he's not ready for
mashenka yet but and let's say two years
from now I like to see those guys
friends yeah they're saying the problem
he's got is he so good there's nobody
really around to give him a legacy you
know you fought all the big ones you
know Ali fought all these great
champions let me take you there's no one
as good as him so he can't have these
big fights that everyone wants to see
where weight classes he wins I have to
keep fighting for many years yes what is
he he's light middleweight like a light
135 yeah the little guy very math but my
god he was impressive it was he doesn't
breathe if nothing is simple it's easy
it's just like that it's like the toad
is just like under that sits in the flow
yeah it's good stuff
who's the greatest fighter you sing man
listen anyway just anyone
you're such an ally right oh my god
Fulham sciatica garlic is the best but
listen man um Chavez was magnificent for
instance let's talk about Chavez you
know Floyd is making a big thing I love
floyd food is the best I disagreed the
flu for so many years but him he made me
believe it he's the best okay
we just think flew 150 fights he's
undefeated madness
Chavez stop 275 he was undefeated at 75
men and he stopped 275 not forget that
man if he stopped at 85 no so I think he
start to what he got me there what 89 90
fight and I need to fight something like
that you know it's crazy when you pass
that recognition you know I'm Vanessa
he's your way you're not Rocky Marciano
wait the heavyweight should be the 50
you know guy they should break the
record North stuff you know somebody
should go after that bag say what 89 and
he's 89 I know somebody should go after
that record that is purely
unmatchable okay and I would live in
that period was just an incredible watch
that
to watch that ride I think it's willing
to fight after fight that's a fight
frame every month every two weeks is
frightening a little a fight and fight
and fight two guys fight that much not
work yeah you got a championship with
ten fights now yeah
lemon shank a fool like 300 plus mm oh
yeah I mean that's an amazing statistic
it's probably wise a good Willie pepper
had 300 M professional fights I like
that yeah Willie better look him up whoa
math for you all II would always be
number one yeah listen um you look at
hourly he was just magically he doesn't
even look like a fight he looking more
like a model didn't he looks like a
fighter you know me but when it comes
down to fighting that in to the right to
the guts of them frightened with you got
at the last second he's gonna out dog
get the end
he's the animal he's gonna fight you too
you can't fight them what he their
endurance fighter you gotta be ready to
fight 15 rounds of gym he you're not
knocking a mountain it's pride you got
to be prepared to go the distance gotta
be endured even you got to be ready this
go 15 rounds before you even think about
even be I met him once at the Beverly
Wilshire in LA hilarious night cuz I had
dinner with Jerry Springer who was the
new host of America's Got Talent when I
was a judge
so we went out get to know each other
right I made dinner at mr. Chow's and we
walked back afterwards and during dinner
he'd said to me he said this show I'd do
is it's a worst TV show in the world he
said it's the worst in the world but it
pays me so much money I can't give it up
and he said you know who watches my show
all the time I saw him a few months ago
Muhammad Ali watches my show everywhere
every day so so I was like I was
thinking to myself [ __ ] there's no
way Muhammad Ali told you he watches
this right this is [ __ ] I'm Vicky
now Jerry's bring a euro [ __ ] I
didn't say it I was thinking it so we
would get this Mike we walk back ask
Jerry the story we walk back from the
hotel from the restaurant we get to the
Beverly Wilshire which has the valet
parking in the middle with the two wings
right and we're both in the back wing so
we walk through valet parking as we get
to valet parking a stretch limousine
pulls up its Muhammad Ali and his wife
get out of the stretch limousine this is
20 minutes after he told me this story
right so now I'm like
well now we're gonna find out aren't we
and all I remember is two things one I
remember the incredible reverence of all
the staff at the hotel when they saw
Muhammad Ali people were literally
bowing to him some were in tears it was
amazing I've never seen this right this
guy could move be nervous just by his
exist crazy and the second thing I
remember is they got out of the car
and Muhammad Ali's wife said Oh Muhammad
is Jerry Springer hey Jerry he's still
watching the show listen marty was the
guy poet at first he was a serious
journalist when he first started doing
this show and when he started doing that
pregnancy stuff you are not a different
career he's a serious journey with the
[ __ ] Jerry was a mad a news anchor
he had to resign as mayor because he
beep a slip with a prostitute and paid
it by personal Oh
Jerry I could even play with a personal
check
big raise a great guy and I always
believed everything he ever told me
again
but Muhammad Ali got out the card on
this remember medium I can remember
every second of it and he was pretty
stooped by then and didn't really think
very much but he had this aura by him
which was extraordinary and I said to
what do you like the Springer Show he
went I like the fighting well I
obviously got run out of the country so
I went back home for a bit I'm hosting
the morning show in Britain called good
morning Britain awesome I mean writing
on YouTube yeah II know we're funny this
would you ladies yes Susanna Reid yeah
yeah no we have good fun and we're
ratings are going big you were having
fun everyone's coming on
on the show we won't have Mike I can't
go I can't do the show you're gonna stay
up late right into the show because I
can't go to England
yeah but what time a criminal record you
Skype in we could do something yet work
something up I used to go all the time
until after Mandela died they said they
made this lourdes lady made this little
you serve more than three years or so
you can't go to England now [ __ ] I can
you know uh it's that way you can appeal
it all um listen know who I was talking
to Tony Blair yeah he was at my friend's
house and they haven't didn't I happened
to meet him there and he said this is
ridiculous I it must be something I can
do and we're gonna find that it's just
nothing I feel good about it
it's ridicu the people we let in our
country look at the people come from
your country well I'm gonna campaign
we're gonna fight to bring women and
different um kind of counties and stuff
they brag about who lip the best killers
and stuff and those are the toughest
guys in their neighborhood an F serial
killer the tougher your serial killer
yes so um
testosterone orientated in England yeah
we love a good fight in England and we
love a good fighter but I guess what
Mike so revered in England they loved
him I was so crazy one day I'm in
England I fight and I beat the promoter
up you know I got mad to promote it uh
just something with my money he's gonna
dawn Kings friends and at the time was
mad at Donna and I mean I was just I
don't know what I was doing with my life
back then you were just pissed off there
and what I know I was making so much
money
what was I mad about Oh ladies I didn't
like myself back then I didn't think I
was worthy of all that stuff had all
these people listen people are diving in
front of my cars and I mean thousands of
people you know I'm inside a prison this
stuff right I mean you can't believe
this the English people he is totally
overwhelming suddenly I saw one of your
podcast they were talking about your
level of Fame and I was discussing it
with my son's on the way here that we're
trying to think of
there aren't many more famous people on
this planet than my Tyson Donald Trump
would be one you know when he was alive
Nelson Mandela Princess Diana when she
was alive but currently alive right now
you know Muhammad Ali is sadly well
there are not many more famous people
than Mike on this planet I mean
everybody knows who you are as I said
there was Paco it's a trip what does
that make you feel like that I don't
know um great question piers
I think about what I've liked what I've
endured to establish that you know a lot
of self degradation self hate and stuff
and why but why you do you think Mike
maybe so many fighters you know some you
know great fighters but for some reason
you captivated the imagination of the
world in a way that very few sportsmen
period have done well I studied the
great fighters and I studied a period
periodically studied their lives and if
the views the great English fighters
Jimmy Wilde and all those guys and I
what I've learnt about them is that they
come from extremely humble means just
extremely and this is what always blew
my mind how they come from you can't
imagine the humble means they come from
and then a timely advice next thing you
know that they've rubbing shoulders with
queens and kings and emperors and people
admiring them and they come from that's
the life they had a nice - what the [ __ ]
and those guys expect those guys uh
inspired me and I wanted to be right
though and so I guess I wanted to be the
best I could I wanted to meet everybody
I wanted to know everybody I was
everybody they know me I want to perform
in front of everybody
did you ever meet Mandela yes what was
that like he came to New York at the
United Nations when he came there and
the first thing he said with is Mike
Tyson live after I beat Michael Spinks
the first things that can I have his
gloves I sent him the gloves the ones
you walk yeah he was enough that he was
still locked up though I sent him a
glove really yeah to Robin on it yes
really his family and then when you met
him what was that like for you he's very
humble man no God like in his very um
then like type of guy
the awesome did he know about boxing was
the above the fighter he used to be a
professional fighter really I didn't
know that fascinating have you met the
Dalai Lama Mike no I have no I asked the
Dalai Lama a series of questions right
because he's the most cool guy when you
made it but he loves super thanks I know
why but he does interesting because he's
never had it right we're sitting I said
have you have you ever had sex he said
no no I said what do you feel when you
see a pretty woman he said I say oh
they're pretty woman and then I say
remember you are monk you are Dalai Lama
and then I have to cool down I said if
you've had a drink alcohol it drink no
never had a drug no I said do you ever
watch movies he said no well not even a
Richard Gere movie he's gonna be so
pissed off what he is this he said nope
I said do you watch television
no I said American Idol isn't the
biggest thing on TV at the time he said
no I said do you know Simon Cowell is
what is that that's a very good question
and then we went through everything and
I said Jesus into music no not really I
said what do you do
you said I'm Dalai Lama he said I read
he reads everything credibly intelligent
man he's outlived almost every other
world leader apart from Queen Elizabeth
the second in Britain he's met everybody
had a very interesting take on American
presidents his favorite was George Bush
jr. loved
w-which very few people and he loved he
got on very toes liked it just got on
with him I've been treated with
competence but he's eager it would be a
conversation you should get him on the
podcast he will talk about sex for as
long as you want to talk about it and I
think he's because well why would he
talk about sex we know nothing of it
what was it I think he's just very
curious about it I asked him know what
did he say to you about it
I said how do you control you know you
must eat for me you actually have a math
debate before I didn't get into the nah
so that might be good question I can
leave that for you to ask him but man
that would
cerium here's a kind of real serenity of
it yes 80 now and and he's got a great
sense of humor I couldn't do a selfie
with my phone I thought I was hilarious
he was like puckering up as tough I'm
he's a very intriguing character and
yeah he's the spiritual leader of so
many people I found it I found it very
evil was he know about the could you
tell him if you say something like do
you know who Alexander the greatest did
he know that big history he's good on ya
probably knows history and current
affairs he'd be very up to speed
he just doesn't waste time with what he
calls road trail stuff yeah he doesn't
bother with trivia movies I don't think
nothing in life is tribute everything
has a right in this he need to be
discovered
you need to be searched it's interesting
it's an interesting idea about that you
know like how does a guy who hasn't
really experienced anything understand
what does he know about love it's
interesting right how do these with um
right concept of love that all of us
need to go to heaven how did he conflict
that with spirituality you know who else
has never had a drink cigarette or drug
Donald Trump brotherbrother go Fred it
was about 10 years old let me tell you
sent right Nietzsche you never had no
puss in like first time Nietzsche here
[ __ ] caught the claps all right nobody
died to film time and put the quits bad
who's it Nietzsche fedja cocky yeah
interesting one timing [ __ ] how many got
the clap first time it's [ __ ] up man
that's some dark [ __ ] he that kind of
dark days dark dude he manifested that
maybe who do you most want to get on
your podcast mine excuse me who do you
most want to get your 3b you guys people
more like this domestic tapes this guy
Sadhguru
oh yeah yeah yeah Houston John Canon she
was good good how am I getting up it's a
very nice full my Luckies podcast it's
funny when I talk to people are from
like Europe other parts of the world in
some word because they look at life from
a deeper perspective than us
they're human from another perspective
they have different human we have yeah I
think that's so we're the kind of guys
like American guy like me if I feel a
train of the guy laughs holy [ __ ] what
stopped you something like English
people people must be fascinating you
know you know I don't know we're
interesting people with all the same but
we're not mmm yeah there's like it
there's a depth
I think and a richness in people from
older civilizations yeah I think we have
such left patients than they do to hold
the countries more impatient yeah well
because you have less you have less to
base it on historically you know you're
in a rush America to be bigger better
and everything else but you know have
any historical perspective where great
countries have gone through lots of
highs and lows what do you think think
you've been here before
in a previous life yeah that's a good
question I find it I think that our
brains can't really compute the reality
of life outside our own existence on
this planet
our brains are too small to really
understand it I was reading an
astonishing thing on Twitter the other
day
some scientists put it up astrology so
the key was and it was about the size of
this planet compared to the rest of the
galaxies out whoo and we're not just a
pinprick we're a pinprick of a pinprick
right you know this planet is one of
this in this solar system and there are
a gazillion solar systems each you know
massively finger galaxies right it's
just it's a black hole that discovered
right eating the different you know I
mean it was around the black hole
picture the camera and it just reminded
me that we just have no idea out there
no I was raised a Catholic right so you
know we I have my religious beliefs from
when I was a kid I'm not the most ardent
Catholic you're ever gonna meet but I
certainly I was brought up that way no
you actually had spiritual guidance from
nuns Catholic nuns which was very
helpful
as a kid you know but I do think that we
don't really we can't comprehend life
before or after this life were in and
it'd be fascinating to know part of me
thinks I may have been here before and
part of me is pretty convinced there's a
life afterwards because I refuse to
believe that we could be having this
existence yeah this creation here and
then that's just it in a ricky gervais
one interview him is adamant that's just
it and I will say to him but you're
gonna be bummed when you're wrong dude
right you know right and you're coming
back now so I'm gonna I love love how is
this over house this is athis as if I
just turned off the switch and it's over
how does that work I don't believe
that's not happens it doesn't make sense
to me Mike let me ask you a question
what if you take the idea of
reincarnation with six billion and
growing souls on the planet where's all
this energy coming from if so many of us
are recycled and we come back in another
form over and over again there are more
and more souls coming in exactly I
thought that's why I have to look at my
lower soul I look at my life not being
concerned with my life I have nothing to
do my life had nothing to do with me
right everything I've done in life has
nothing to do with me it have to do with
the Creator yes
that source yes you know when I took
another time when I took the toll that I
felt all the pain that everybody ever
hurt I thought all their pain
interesting you get released from a lot
of pain from with the toes piers have to
up a lot in here do it do up I did heard
with my prayers yeah try this tight I
think it's time for me in the toad to
encounter each other for good medicine I
did to toto probably a you go right I
don't think exactly yeah but I know that
and I thought about that before but I
never I never thought that I wasn't
always thought about who in my way I
never thought why am I here what is my
purpose here it can't be to knock out
people to applaud to me and make me
think that I'm somebody special
after taking a toy like that I don't
even exist I don't even know if I exist
at this moment I just know I'm here you
know you look for deep perspectives in
yourself and you realize that wow it's
almost over I've did all that stuff I
thought I did everything I'm live my
life I'm 52 years old and I've almost
over what am i doing now what do I do
about how do I am how do I make amends
with myself I don't know very
interesting very interesting
I believe that we're just we are the
physical manifestations of the universal
mind you know consciousness is
everything outside everything and then
we just get this opportunity to be in
these physical bodies to see what that
experience is like well I would say I
said to Ricky Gervais see I said what
what was there before nothing a theist
can never tell you right they like
rhodium as well what was there before
nothing and if you can't answer the
question you have to accept our brains
on big enough to comprehend this stuff
we can't company in that star right yeah
all right
you know me how do I do the last so long
why does it keep [ __ ] getting
brighter and why can't we stop that
you're talking about yourself no Mike no
why can't we we have no control I was
reading about the Rockefellers yesterday
um dude these guys keep coming up my
listen right they couldn't give their
money away fast enough they couldn't
give it away it was too much it was
crushing them it didn't give it away
fast enough crazy
have you read about any of the weird
conspiracies about them and the
Rothschilds know yet that the Rothschild
financed every war since Napoleon you
know that kind of stuff listen it was
one particular story of our sort of look
in this documentary and um there was
other very wealthy Jewish families too
that you know started like honey they
got caught up in
tracing camp and they stole everything
devastated their finances and stuff and
the rough charges managed to be luckily
people stole all the stuff Diaz managed
to going to other countries in this he
is never lost he has kept accumulating
wealth and so now this is dumb xxx this
is doing this during the time of Hitler
so let's go now is it's now it's now
like yesterday and I'm looking and
they're still friends this their
families are still friends but they're
not wealthy mmm but they're still
friends you know I mean Germany
devastated them but there's still no
limits and again it continues to go on
life continues to go on if you survive
it and that's what it's all about being
grateful for your life right that was
pretty interesting I thought hmm have
you seen our show before he came on
Pierce I watched two episodes yesterday
oh nice Terry Crews and Mickey Rourke
those were good I don't know Terry
that's very good and I know Mickey and
if I did a big interview with him for
British television just before the
wrestler came out so he was still in
that wilderness yeah you know he was
like he thought it may never come back
and then the wrestler became his
comeback movie yeah and he was at his
most roar and kind of Mickey Rourke oh
yeah and the wrestler and once the
wrestling was a hit he was sort of back
in the old Mickey Rourke yeah well I got
him when he was really quite vulnerable
he's really intense though right yeah
yeah yeah yeah and he's you know he's
got in the ring him and I have already
won I guess in the ring for sure he is
so crazy
yeah why would he go in and he's guy was
gonna kill him man he's so crazy right
he just loves it that he loves that well
it's been great having you man love it
I've loved it it's been brilliant so
awesome it's been a real pleasure you're
great come back anytime don't don't do
this too often you took it of it
everybody episode thank you awesome
guest this morning I'm Mike Tyson I'm
have been pretty
hey do you want anybody to know anything
uh I just watched good morning Britain
if you if your morning Brit and get it
yeah good morning Britain yeah much
closer to what am I supposed to do with
this my smoke it When in Rome right
[Music]